Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be a video All about how
the flash has to level up to beat savitar
and in doing so unlock his greatest new ability.
There's so many things that the flash is capable
of doing in the comics.
Each new season They only do a few of those.
This is going to be all about the biggest
one for this season and there is a new round
of the injustice to giveaway I'm giving away
a copy of the game.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a flash related comment on this
video so be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of my episode
videos there were a lot of great powers that
he learned during season two.
Probably the biggest most powerful one was
creating the time remnant to aid him in his
fight against zoom literally creating a copy
of himself using a form of time travel then
convincing that other copy to kill himself
trying to destroy that giant device that was
going to crush the multi-verse.
The other big ones were traveling between
worlds that was like the new big thing, but
he was only able to do that with extra technology
from the rest of the team.
So sometimes flash is only able to do things
with the help of the entire team or like with
Jay Garrick or the reverse flash achieved
greater than normal speeds just running normally.
And even that Harrison wells reverse flash
helped him build the tachyon device which
made him temporarily faster than zoom but
only by a little bit he was able to hold onto
that and eventually zoom was able to beat
them again till he got to the finale.
So really like the only other big major major
new ability that he learned about was the
speed force itself doesn't totally understand
it but he was able to become pure speed force
energy and get sucked up into the speed force
crossing that dimensional barrier that only
speedsters can cross the tradition on the
flash thus far the last couple of seasons
has been for him to learn new abilities based
on the things that he does the challenges
that he faces in previous seasons.
So like when he's saving Wally West at the
very beginning of the season.
He creates those win funnels that's like a
very rudimentary ability but when he first
learned about that.
It was a really big deal.
So with time he gets a lot better at the really
casual powers within there's really big problems
he faces where he has to level up big time.
So in the grand tradition of videogame RPG's
he has to get XP so that he can level of throughout
each season.
This season so far just at the episode nine.
He seen a couple challenges that he is not
strong enough to face.
So he is definitely going to have to unlock
a couple new abilities either by meeting with
others speedsters who have abilities that
he doesn't have or with the help of team flash
learning new science of the speed force.
That's another thing to learning about the
science of things Jay Garrick springing a
more spiritual approach to things which is
kind of Max Mercury from the comics so that
also plays into this to, but he needs to save
Iris from dying at the hands of savitar defeat's
savitar somehow and then also we learn about
the black flash.
That is coming back.
This season is going to be defeating death
itself, which is something that goes back
all the way to the Wally West era of the flash
were the black flash first debuted.
So while these all seem like different problems
defeating death defeating the black flash
who basically is the death of the speedsters
defeating savitar saving Iris.
They all seem like different problems, but
really they're all connected at the end of
the day, so there was this very specific progression
that Wally West had during the grant Morrison
Mark Millar right before Geoff Johns came
on the title and he learned to defeat death,
the black flash During this arc called the
human race.
So like when people say that Wally West is
the fastest version of the flash he's so fast
that he can run faster than teleportation
he could run to the end of the universe and
back in an instant.
That's all from that same black flash story
arc it sort of culminates in the black flash
appearing where he defeats death after he's
done all these great things but on the way
to unlocking that ability.
There's a couple other smaller abilities that
he asked unlock first first.
Yes to get super Zen about it, which is where
you get to Max Mercury.
But that's kind of like Jay Garrick on the
TV show helping Barry achieve this nirvana
state were he's capable of tapping into all
of his potential which is really what's keeping
them down right now he's so bummed out and
freaked by this Iris situation that he sort
of shutting himself off from all these possibilities
that's one of the problems of the Barry Allen
flash as well as the Wally West flash in the
comics is that they have infinite potential
but there only capable of utilizing all those
powers.
Unlocking those abilities if their heads are
clear and that is definitely not Barry on
the TV show right now which is why TV show
Wally West is leveling up so much faster than
Barry did because there's nothing that he's
bummed out about he is so jazzed up that he
has speed force powers that's always thinking
about getting faster, just having fun and
in previous seasons that's usually when Barry
was at his best, so this season before he
can unlock that ability outrun death itself
first.
Yes to be able to clear his head put everything
into perspective and trust the rest of the
team then he'll be able to face the black
flash and that will give him the ideas he
needs for defeating savitar because as powerful
is the black flash is easy instant death for
any of the speedsters that he catches savitar
is still the big boss.
So he will be around to the very final episode.
They did not say how long the black flash
is going to be around for the season but he
just another step on the way to Barry learning
the solution to savitar and.
A lot of that goes into the flash family also
leveling up so we also has to learn to train
the team be a good leader, which is something
that he's not doing really well right now.
So he has to train Wally he has to train Jesse
quick hatefully we have Jay Garrick around
to help him out with that.
And they tease that there will be other speedsters
of the multi-verse it might be able to do
things that Barry can't do that will give
them new ideas in it all goes back to this
really cool Mark Wade arc called terminal
velocity where this is during the Wally West
era remember Barry Allen is in around the
Wally learns about the speed force and gets
a vision of the future, where he has ultimate
power but learns that if he uses that ultimate
power he will have to leave all the people
he loves behind and joined the speed force.
The twist is that yes to say, the love of
his life.
Linda Park from dying but he has to use this
ultimate power in order to do that.
Meaning that he would then join the speed
force and never be able to see her again so
do you save the love of your life if it means
you'll never get to see her again.
That will be part of the ark the season.
They only borrow arcs from the comics the
never do them out right in this is from way
back during Wally West run, but it's Mark
Wade is probably one of the best stories that
he ever wrote that is called terminal velocity
if you want to read that you can check that
out.
There's a lot of that stuff you will see on
the flash season three.
But it will be exactly like it is in the comics,
so Barry in unlocking this greatest power
the power to defeat death might end up never
being able to see Iris again.
But this is only season three of the flash
so obviously there can have to take some different
route with it because it's not like grant
Gustin is no longer going to be on the show
in season four it's not can it be Wally show
they actually address that last year when
people are like hey what can happen when you
bring all the other versions of the flash
on and they were like it's not called flash
and friends.
It's called the flash and Barry Allen will
always be the main character.
The central storyline even though they're
building out all the other characters, there's
a lot of Caitlin stuff is going to be happening
in the back half of the season so we can talk
about that when we get there but let me know
what you guys think about the flash is greatest
new power this season being able to out run
death it's self for those you asking about
the schedule this week because legends of
tomorrow is on Tuesday night what can happen
is is I'll try to get all those videos out
by Wednesday like legends will have to post
on Wednesday because flash will post Tuesday
nights.
I will try to get arrow out by Wednesday night
but if I don't it'll be a Thursday morning
video so no worries, I'll get everything out,
but Tuesday to Thursday will be pretty regular
with the DC TV stuff and then I'll be doing
Star Wars stuff Thursdays and Fridays for
the rest of the year.
Pretty much, but all explained that as I post
new Star Wars videos.
So as long as you have alerts turned on to
get all the videos no worries, it will be
awesome what can happen next is I'll be posting
some more new Star Wars episode eight.
Congratulations to the new injustice to giveaway
winner wild boy 24 just private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner when I
post that next flash episode video on Tuesday
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about Star Wars episode
8 the last Jedi and click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash thank you
so much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight!